and so if you don't believe in mass
mandates and you don't believe in
vaccine mandates
then how are we going to get out of this
instead of trying to convince people to
do the things you think they should do
instead you just yell at them and you
don't explain things to them and then
when they don't do it you say ah you are
the problem the reason that a lot of
people are not vaccinating according to
the left of course it's the right and
tucker carlson and all of that
but the real reason that nobody or a few
a bunch of people are not vaccinated
including a lot of people in blue states
is because institutional trust is down
now the left believes that the
institutions should be trusted no matter
what because institutions are more
important than actual human beings
this is why you will hear people like
anthony fauci say if you contradict me
it's because you don't believe in the
science the science
right it's like well no you're not the
science trademark
you are actually just a scientist and
apparently
very often a guy who makes mistakes
about that the institutional trust
problem continues unabated
you can't trot out andrew cuomo to kill
all the olds in new york and then also
try out andrew cuomo to be your lead
spokesperson on get the vax you can't
you can't do that it's just not going to
be effective
and yet that's exactly what's happening
so here was andrew cuomo yesterday
explaining that
you should get vaccinated which by the
way i agree with but when andrew cuomo
says it i'm like i'm not
sure i believe that you are the proper
spokesperson
for this especially when you say things
like this right andrew cuomo
who lied about like half a dozen things
in in his state
he says i've told you the truth since
day one
i hmm told you the facts on covid
from day one whether they were
easy whether they were hard i told
you the truth while a lot of people were
talking politics
and a lot of people were talking theory
and a lot of people were trying to deny
because they didn't want to deliver
bad news i told you the truth
you know why because i believe in you
oh why won't people trust our
institutions
the man is still covering up how many
people died in nursing homes by
reclassifying people who got sick in
nursing homes and lived in nursing
homes as not dying in nursing homes if
they died in a hospital
meanwhile you've got jen saki over at
the white house she was asked
specifically you know there are some
people who are infected at the white
house by the texas democrats who showed
up
on their doorstep by the way i am amused
the texas democrats
are um now doing like gofundme
fundraisers
for ramen or something it's like i'm
pretty sure they can afford that like do
they have credit cards how does that
in any case apparently they infected a
bunch of democrats in the white house
and jen saki was asked who in the white
house has a covet infection
here was her answer has the white house
had any additional
staffers test positive for coping 19. i
think again
our policy just to reiterate it which we
announced last week is that
if there's an individual who is has
close proximity
to any of the four principles as defined
by the white house medical unit in line
with cdc guidelines on what that looks
like
we will then make that information
available and immediately public to all
of you
so that has not been the case since we
announced that policy no
uh so i'm supposed to trust you guys
about like coveted vaccinations and
coveted infections and you won't even
say who in the white house has coveted
and by the way this was not the rule
during the trump administration if a
low-level trump administration official
got coveted
and it was like okay that was big
national news meanwhile joe biden gets
irritated by even being asked questions
so yesterday there was an announcement
from the veterans administration
that if you work in a va hospital
they're going to mandate that you get
vaccinated which actually i gotta say i
don't think is like
the world's worst policy again if you're
working in a hospital you're literally
working with people who are ill and have
serious pre-existing conditions every
single day
many of whom can't get vaccinated so
that's a different situation than you're
working a bus
at the mta okay but that's not really
the point the point here is that joe
biden gets
angry when people ask him questions the
first rule by the way
of of convincing people to believe you
as an authority figure is explaining
yourself
nobody never wants to explain himself
because he's sort of an old crotchety
dude who
who believes that everybody should just
believe what he has to say
veterans affairs is going to have a man
you are such a pain in the neck but i'm
going to answer your question because
you've known he said that for so long it
has nothing to do with iraq
the answer no i'll answer your question
yes veteran affairs is going to in fact
require
that all docs working in that and
facilities
are going to have to be vaccinated
you're such a pain in the neck you're a
pain in the neck if you ask questions
did you buy in your opinion in the next
genesaki
yesterday she suggested that we're going
to continue to keep travel bans in place
from various places on earth
despite the fact that it's not working
right the delta variance is already
widely seated in the united states there
is no data to suggest
that preventing travel from europe to
the united states is going to cut down
on the number of infections in the
united states considering that the delta
variants is running roughshod
through the population that is
unvaccinated but here she is again
proposing policies that don't make sense
given where we are today and i think
you've seen this and those of you have
asked we've confirmed this for
with the delta variant we will maintain
existing travel restrictions at this
point for a few reasons
the more transmissible delta variant is
spreading both here and around the world
driven by the delta variant cases are
rising here at home particularly among
those who are unvaccinated
and appear likely to continue in the
weeks ahead
okay maybe the reason why people don't
trust any of these authority figures
is because these authority figures have
not earned the trust of the american
people
by the way there's bipartisan failure
here if you don't explain your policy
and you don't do it clearly and
concisely
and you don't take seriously concerns
nobody is going to pay attention to you
and instead the move of the left is to
browbeat and i think there there's a
specific political
reason for that because if you browbeat
then you can treat anybody who doesn't
listen as an enemy
instead of trying to convince people to
do the things you think they should do
instead you just yell at them
and you don't explain things to them and
then when they don't do it you say ah
you are the problem
you're the problem for example last
night
on cnn you had ellison camerata and she
was grilling
the mayor of a uh of a missouri town
on why he opposed a mass mandate now the
reason to oppose a mask mandate at this
point
for the vaccinated is because the
vaccinated are vaccinated
okay and and the idea that we are going
to force people who are vaccinated to
mask up to protect the unvaccinated who
have had every opportunity to go get the
vaccine
and still have the opportunity to go
back get the vaccine the data to support
a mass mandate on the vaccinated
is really really weak at best and it is
a serious violation of freedom for
people
who did the thing that you they were
supposed to do but here are the
hosts of cnn alison cameron and victor
blackwell trying to browbeat
the the wildwood mayor jim balon saying
you know you need a mass maintained you
need it right now
please explain why you think that a mask
mandate is necessary from the government
at this time
seriously they won't they'll just brow
beat them
i just want to give people a status
report of where your county is
hospitalizations are up the number of
people in icus are up the number of
people on ventilators are up
so why not make people wear masks
indoors for a little while until you get
the numbers down
let me ask you and i i don't mean this
to be insulting but we've had some
people who have been against local
mass mandates answered this question in
a way that would lead us in a different
part of the
conversation do you believe that masks
work
to block and mitigate the virus people
are
dying in st louis county they're on
ventilators they're in the hospital
and so if you don't believe in mass
mandates and you don't believe in
vaccine mandates
then how are we going to get out of this
okay so that is not journalism at this
point this is just brow beating
by the way i'm looking right now at st
louis county the number of
deaths the seven day rolling average in
st louis county of death is according to
the new york times
one that is the seven day rolling
average in st
louis county what you get from cnn is
people are dying everyone's saying by
the way this guy's answer was actually
quite good
right his answer was if the standard is
now going to be that every time there's
an uptick in kovid and without
vaccinations and so forth it stays
around in perpetuity
presumably we'll be doing masks in
perpetuity forever he is correct
emergency authority is to be used when
there's an emergency and if you prolong
the emergency
by suggesting that people who don't do
what you say are the emergency
you have now created the impetus to cram
down whatever you want for all time
and the left is in love with this you're
going to see them do this on global
warming you're going to see them do this
on quote-unquote income inequality
you're going to see them do this with
regards to the quote-unquote racial
reckoning
everything is an emergency and if it's
an emergency you require emergency
powers
and the emergency can never end because
any if anyone opposes you
their mere presence on the world stage
is the emergency
even if the externalities no longer
exist because everyone has the ability
to get a vaccine if you're an adult
hey this is a power grab pure and simple
it is scary and it should frighten
anybody who gives a damn
about baseline freedom in the united
states i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the ben shapiro show
if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button so you stay up to date
with all our future content